the latest development in the Trump
indictments out of Georgia this is from
CBS 17 Trump lawyers seek April 2026
trial date in federal election
subversion case that's basically the
story the suggested date is a dramatic
counter to the doj to the Justice
Department's recommendation last week of
January 2nd oh I'm sorry this is the
federal judge I had this uh totally
wrong it's not the Georgia case this is
the federal election wait no no this is
a federal election says why do they say
a federal judge he's asking a federal
judge to intervene lawyers for Donald
Trump asked a federal judge Thursday
night to set an April 2026 trial date in
the case in Washington charging the
former president with conspiring okay
right so this is this is a Jack Smith
case so this is the DC case not the
Georgia case man it's it's hard to keep
track of all these indictments I thought
this was Georgia then there's four but
this I mean look the reality is that
they've got to figure out something here
because you can't have the leading
candidate for the Republican nomination
who's leading Joe Biden having to deal
with I mean they can't have it both ways
I I think the one thing that that is
lost in this whole discussion and and I
watched one of the media organizations
today try to excuse this but the reality
is every one of those four cases
happened the the issue that he's being
charged with happened years ago why did
all four now happen it's weird it's
crazy but I'm sitting here watching this
County uh D.A go after him for an event
that happened two and a half years ago
why did it take and oh by the way it
just so happens to sequence right after
Jack Smith's case which just happened to
sequence after Jack Smith's other case
which happened to sequence right after
Alvin bragte all of these events
happened two and a half years ago if
what Trump did was so bad what new has
occurred nothing in Georgia they the
court published the indictments against
Trump before the grand jury convened but
that was a mistake sure yeah first I
said it was fictitious then they said we
hit the wrong button right but then
here's argument off Donald Trump came
out um I haven't seen the video but I
saw someone tweeting about it
apparently Donald Trump said that
everyone else should drop out of the GOP
Primary race
that they should all we should all be
United and uh let me see if actually let
me let me let me pull up the uh I can I
can actually try and pull this video up
so someone asked I want to make sure I
get the person who has to write I'll
play the video for you guys
I didn't pull it up before but I'll pull
it up now
and uh let's see where we at
did I not did it not go through maybe it
didn't go through on my Twitter so
Trump apparently said that everyone
should drop out
and I think I think that's that's
correct I believe that all of the
Republicans should drop out of the race
Trump should be the only one and the
question is but what happens when they
remove Trump from the uh from the
ballots in various States I think Trump
should put that decision Dilemma to the
Democrats to say there is no one else
running for the GOP it is Biden or Trump
or Newsom or Trump whatever it's going
to be and they would have to remove
republican from the ballots outright if
they want to remove Trump right now if
there's other contenders there's a
safety net if it's Rhonda santis or
Vivek or anybody else if they remove
Trump from the ballot they'll put on
some other Republican so that way the
people who are there perceive this this
this option I think that's a that's a
decision dilemma either they a lot they
keep they're stopped from removing Trump
or they're forced to take such an
extreme and egregious action they will
shock people to their course
well I I mean I think the analysis might
be right but the reality is no each of
these guys who are running think somehow
that Trump's going to fall and they're
going to be the next person that's
what's keeping them in the race I mean
they all know I I made I don't want to
get ahead of the debate discussion if we
get there tonight but someone asked you
I get asked every day should Trump go to
the debate and I go he's at 54 in the
real clear average of polls most of
these folks need a name tag for you to
know who they are right so why should he
get on the stage and the same thing is
true they're all hoping that what you're
saying to him happens that he goes down
and they become the number two or the
number three the reality is that's all
they're hoping for they know they can't
win I mean no one at in their right mind
anyone who just has second grade math
says he's at 54. I'm trying to get to
one
I get it and that's even if you start
breaking it down by the states Iowa New
Hampshire it's not so they know their
only hope is that he falls down and gets
removed or something or gets the Vegas
has said no way to that and fake is
publicly resisting that saying I don't
want to win that way I want to win on
the merits and that we can't handle this
uh we can't handle this way so the Tweet
was from Jessie Kelly but I want to play
first the clip from Donald Trump here's
what Trump had to say great poll is just
out leading by 40 50 and even 60 points
who expected that I did Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina all very strong
but also leading Biden very big
to sanctimonious is crashing perhaps the
party should come together people should
drop out of the race we unify and we
beat Biden and the Democrats they should
be easy to beat because our country has
never been in worse condition
than it is right now thank you
so this tweet from Jessie Kelly says
someone explained to me like I'm a 10
year like I'm 10 years old how does
anyone dropping out help Trump stay out
of prison please be specific if everyone
drops out what do we do when the
Communists in Michigan and Pennsylvania
keep him off the general election ballot
my response was it creates a decision
dilemma for the Dems they either cancel
the GOP entirely or they keep Trump on
taking his name off would be apocalyptic
with others in the race they get a
safety net for nuking Trump
if this goes back to what you said a
moment ago and this is or what we were
talking about I don't here's the deal I
think that you're right it's this
apoplectic decision I don't think they
care I think that they will do what and
this gets back to the nut of what I've
been saying is that they don't care they
will do whatever it takes to maintain
power then force them into a into a
risky position and what happens when we
this is my question what happens when we
lose meaning that they say great we're
going to remove them we're going to jail
them and then we're going to make sure
that Biden wins because no because you
need to avoid the frogs boiling in the
pot scenario if Donald Trump has taken
off the ballot and there are three
people standing behind him then the
ballot in Michigan still has Republican
and Democrat on it but if the ballot has
a single party and no one else that is
such a massive leap the problem we're
experiencing right now we mentioned this
in the beginning of the show every day
people say oh that can't happen that
would go too far you let's go way back
in time and I bring this up all the time
when I said in 2018 that the street
conflicts we are seeing between proud
boys and antifa were a track towards
Civil War and people laughed saying a
bunch of goons fighting in the street is
not a Civil War and I said yes but the
sentiments held by these people will
keep spreading eventually find their
ways into government and they said that
will never happen the security state
will not allow it where are we today
we're well past that point not only did
you have the 2020 Summer of Love riots
where they fire bombed they tried
firebombing the White House the
president was forced into a bunker you
then get January 6th you then get Donald
Trump being indicted several times every
single time someone has suggested that
something like this could happen people
have just across the board across
Twitter saying no that'll never happen
but that goes to the point that's my
that's what I'm saying you're absolutely
right so why is this let me explain so
what's happening is every action they
take is them cranking up the temperature
by one degree you don't notice you're
boiling now that they've indicted
Trump's lawyers like Jenna Ellis what
indicted simply for being his lawyer
counts one and two being party to a
criminal organization and violation of
public oath of office or whatever quite
literally just being his lawyer there
are people on that indictment list where
it's like they reached out to a state
elector and said they reached out to a
lawyer and said this no she's just a
lawyer
when when people said Trump wouldn't be
indicted Mike cernovich brings us up
he's like they're going to indict Trump
all of these people on Twitter these
prominent conservatives like no they
won't it won't happen then when it does
oh Trump gets indicted for what the tax
paperwork some campaign contribution
that's not even a big deal the next day
it's classified documents okay well
that's you know it's not that big a deal
then it's trying to subvert the election
now they're going after his lawyers
what's happening is they're incrementing
it to such a degree that when they now
that they're at the point where they've
indicted lawyers for constitutionally
protected legal work people are acting
like it's no big deal yes so what you
have to do is put the Democrats in a
situation where they either take 10
steps forward or two steps back and 10
steps forward is like cranking the
temperature up past 400 Degrees when all
sudden the frogs shriek and jump out of
the pot
imagine what would happen in Michigan if
your run-of-the-mill bumbling dotted
Republican voter who doesn't pay
attention goes and looks at the ballot
and there's not a single Republican
option or the president just says Joe
Biden that person goes what
this is where I'll disagree with you
because I think that what happens is the
media and the establishment in Hollywood
and everything else they own says well
unfortunately uh he committed these
crimes and he wasn't allowed to do it in
the Republican Party Bubba I mean they
do what they do I get your point they've
turned it up 10 notches doesn't change
anything anything make them
excise the Republican party from the
election force them to outright say you
have one choice or no choice it's the
same thing make them say it okay make
regular people let's play it out for a
second they say it the election happens
and they go see we did have an election
unfortunately the Republicans had
nominated a guy that was in jail and we
had to remove them from the ballot and
so Joe Biden has been dutifully elected
president of the United States for a
second time and oh by the way this is
where Kamal is coming in but I don't
know exactly what happens when they uh
when when does react this is what I'm
trying to get it when does when does
the frogs jump out of the pot they go oh
my God there's only one party and this
is what they're doing to us what's the
recourse how do we undo what they did
this is the problem your your example
about the street everything else and
everybody goes holy crap but we're not
even for all the stuff that they've done
and where we are in society no one's
turning back and saying we've got to
undo it now gosh look at how how hot it
got in the pot and I think they turn it
up a bunch of notches we freak out but
then we go what's the recourse we go oh
it's too late sorry next election so the
reason I believe the reason Democrats
are taking actions is Extreme is because
they know they've lost the culture yes
but my point is but but that means what
they're doing is irrelevant laws are
only enforced on the on the confidence
of the people and they're losing
confidence in people if they take one
party off the ballot outright confidence
evaporates overnight but see I think
that what your example was right they
they don't go hey in all 50 states
there's no Trump right it's Michigan
Pennsylvania right so it just prevents
him from getting to 270. um we did held
an election so what so so here's my
point so what is they declare him they
they go through the same exercise where
the uh the Congress certifies it and
they said sorry guys next time uh you
should nominate somebody you don't think
it'll happen ABS that will not that no
way we as bad as 2020 was in terms of
how many how many members of Congress
challenged the results and demanded
action and and whatever you think of
January 6 we had something on January 6
2024 will not go down like that
especially if they remove Trump from the
ballot in one state and just one state
my point is this the only reason they
get away with anything they do is
because people believe they can
so the example I like to give is that
women aren't legally allowed to skydive
in Florida on Sundays not a single cop
is going to arrest a woman for skydiving
in Florida on Sunday why because the
culture will not allow it we have tons
of laws in the books that never get
enforced it's illegal to do these drag
performances with children in a bunch of
these states ain't no cop stopping them
why because of the culture because the
cops are like I don't want to get
involved the sentiment of the people
matters more than what the letter of the
law says see just to just to bring this
back though for a second here's what I
think I I get your where you're going
with this but I think that there's also
a reality of where I
in my opinion think things are headed
now which is that either in DC or
Georgia they get a conviction
and what they do is they don't take them
off the ballot right that's this is my
take on this but they basically create
an environment to say Republicans you
guys do you really want to elect a guy
that's going to be in jail and so
they've the the elections are such that
Arizona Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin
are all within one two three four
percent you don't need to get 500 000
people against the president you need 10
20 40. Michigan Was Won in 2015 by Trump
by ten thousand seven hundred and three
votes that's it they get that they just
need a little movement of the needle and
they win they win Michigan they win so
what I think they're really doing is
ensuring that they get a conviction in
Washington DC and or in Fulton County
Georgia and that they can spread the
message that you guys are going to elect
a guy who can't get himself out of jail
I don't know and that to me is actually
a worse scenario because they can they
will let Republicans infight on that
whether or not and they don't have to
remove them from the ballot I don't I I
don't see that being as successful that
that is a pyrrhic victory if Democrats
have to win using these methods they are
eroding the American people's confidence
in the system to function and that that
will destroy them that's my point
correct and that's how they lose yes
they have to maintain legitimacy yeah
but see here's my point you you talked
about the legitimacy look where we are
now you pointed out right where we are
in the streets and they're doing it
because of their desperation right
examples Bud Light
30 drop off in their stock 400 million
dollars lost Target 27 drop off in their
stock for the first time in six years
they're dropping in sales meanwhile
sound of Freedom surpasses Indiana Jones
Disney now facing major boycotts a rich
men north of Richmond to debut at number
one yeah because people are starting to
push back culturally and they're losing
so the only thing they have left is raw
power it won't work so let's ask
Republicans over the past 10 years if
political power did anything for them
with no cultural power so
on the sound of freedom and on on target
just to keep it one on one here you're
absolutely right sound of Freedom 100
what probably closing on to 200 million
right now and it's we people went out
saw the movie spread the word we want
Target same thing people were disgusted
by what they saw said I'm not shopping
in there but here's the question let's
look at Target who lost their job
my guess is cat bunch of cashiers but
that's my point is that this is what
scares me is it in any normal World a
decade ago you would have fired that CEO
and said what a you're out you
know who got fired at Bud Light
yeah the marketing team yeah the market
no no just to be clear they didn't get
fired they're on leave no no they were
fired okay all right so the leave was a
lie reportedly fine but here's my point
five people lost 26 what billion dollars
lost I mean and and five people lose
their job you've got everyone else in
the leadership well no uh Bud Light was
forced to sell off their craft brew
Brands to a Canadian company but my
point and they're shutting down several
of their plants and tons of okay so so
let's take this one if Ian starts
blowing up Tim cast you're gonna get you
know 20 minutes later he's out where
where's the accountability I mean yes
they fired the marketing team that's
coward this
they fired the people who did the thing
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time